my name is Victoria Lanza I'm the
executive producer dr. strange I have a
couple of different jobs I'm also the
executive vice president of physical
production at Marvel so we do a little
bit of the studio job a little bit of
the producer job and everything else in
between and you know I was reading
recently a little bit about you
obviously I was doing my research and
you are one of the first if not few
women who are in a position on the
production side for a big studio can you
tell us a little bit about what that
means to you and what that means for the
industry and not only a woman but also
that Tina I think it's a it's exciting
that the doors are opening to capable
people regardless of whether you're a
man or a woman but I think we've seen a
lot of capable men and now we're getting
a chance to have some capable women so
the idea of balance I think it's a
healthy one
so that's what I keep on pushing for the
50/50 rule I call it if you can if you
can have 5050 I think we'll be a little
more balanced a little more what the
world is about I mean women are 51% of
the population so we should have 50
percent or maybe 51% I don't know of the
jobs that's right what is your favorite
part about what you do here at Marvel
you know one of the most exciting things
about it is that sometimes you just
don't know what's coming you think you
have it planned you think you know what
you're doing and then something just
comes as a bit of a tsunami of nope this
is what we're doing because now the
landscape has changed so the possibility
of change is a constant for us and that
is frightening at times and exciting all
at the same time as I'm sure it allows
for you to you know come up with new
creative ways to solve you're on your
feet a lot you know it's like sometimes
you think you have it all figured out
and then you don't and then the next
thing you know is you're at it again and
again and again and you had 13 plans
already for that one thing and now we
need a fourteenth plan so you go with it
it's a it's a it's a nice way to stay
agile both mind and body
so you've worked on quite a few
properties for Marvel already 14 quite a
few
what does Doctor Strange bring to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's a little
different than the rest of them Doctor
Strange is special there's something
about it that is different and I think
part of it is that it has a lot to do
with the spiritual side of what this
character has to go to and through so he
has to be at the bottom of the bottom to
realize that the bottom is the beginning
and it could take him to Heights that
he's never been to and I think that at
some point in our lives we've all been
to a place where we feel is a bottom or
a bad place and we rise from it and I
think that sometimes you rise with the
help of someone or you rise because
within you find the spiritual guidance
and the strength to get there and I
think that in a way we say this in the
movie whether you see it or you don't
yourself then it's really about you if
you want to see that layer but that
layer is there and from sort of a more
technical perspective what was exciting
for you about working on Doctor Strange
I know one of your big sort of
specialties is VFX yeah well there was a
chance to take all these multiverses and
different dimensions and turn them
inside out so we you know we do a lot of
things that are incredibly for real and
then we had to create him first and then
completely tear them apart so that was a
fun part to tear something apart in a
way that you can still tell your story
that is visually stunning that is a
little bit dizzying if you would and yet
people could follow the story in a
whichever dimension you're in and it
gives you a ride so it was the the
greatest combination of all those things
can you talk about your approach to that
world and sort of like maybe the
pre-production process a little bit and
working
with you know the production designer
and the VFX supervisor well we're
involved you know clearly from the very
beginning from the writer point so
that's sometimes we have writers and
that's when we have previous artists and
visual development all happening
sometimes as before we have a director
on board so we the gestation of it takes
a long time I mean we're been working on
this movie for two and a half years so
that's a long time but so we're where
sometimes script comes first and then
the previous of it all sometimes a scene
gets pitched as what the scene will be
and I guess Prevost and then it gets
written into the script because a lot of
it gets determined by the visuals so
it's a combination of back and forth
between writing and visuals that has to
be hand and hand throughout it's not
just in pre-production it that also
happens in production and very much
happens in post-production absolutely
and then sort of the process of
interpreting this abstract trippy you
know world that was created by Steve
Ditko it's you know quite a departure
from a lot of what we've seen before and
even in the comic universe it's quite
doing something different though that
was that was the one thing that we
wanted to attack because why do the same
over and over so it was it was a chance
to sort of like venture into places that
we had never been and that's what the
multiverse gives us right whether is in
the magic mystery tour on in the Dark
Dimension with our mama or when we go
into the mirror dimension or the astral
plane any of those different places it
was a chance to do something completely
different than we had seen before and
yet believe that this was a journey of a
superhero and so for this movie in
particular and and we've done it in the
past on other films we've decided to
open up the aspect ratio and go into
that special formats IMAX can you talk a
little bit about coming to that decision
and how it works with the story and for
Doctor Strange yeah we had we we this is
not the first project that we've done in
this criteria so we had learned before
with guardians of the galaxy
also with civil war and the idea was
what can we do for this story that will
work for IMAX because we want to tell
that story in mercifully but we also
didn't want to have this cryptic in and
out in and out in and out of the
different ratios so we decided that the
person that dr. strange was up to when
he gets to Kathmandu and Nepal is one
person and the person that he becomes
once he's there is a different person
that's different times of his journey so
what we decided to do is was up to the
arrival to Kathmandu is a two furrow and
once we get to Kathmandu we opened it up
as if you could see that he was growing
and he was learning to be the best of
who he could be so that was it was a
story based and technically visually
pleasing so that it wouldn't take you
out so that that's sort of how we
decided to arrive there so we did over
65 minutes of full-on IMAX yeah I you
know it's it's beautiful it's a really
cool metaphor to think about how you
know he opens his mind so you open the
frame like yeah that was the whole idea
was to have that right so once that he
arrives to the sanctuary and he starts
to learn to open his mind to the
possibilities then the frame opens up
and it just takes you through the
journey until the very end and what have
you guys have you added something extra
into that into that frame like you know
staff was telling us that they had like
placed certain you know they're all
extras into the into the frame for the
IMAX experience for the IMAX experience
if you've seen the movie into four oh
and 2d then when you go to IMAX you're
gonna see things top and bottom I can
tell you what it is and then I won't be
giving it up but there's a lot of things
here there that we added that we thought
it would be a nice treat for people to
go see what did he tell you he's not
allowed to tell you well I
you know Bruce also encourage you guys
to sort of like feel free to be I mean
obviously it's up to you how free you
would like to be with some of the
information but it's out in the world
now you know people have seen it I think
people should experience it for
themselves and see the experience of
IMAX regardless of what's if you have
more or less the experience itself is
what opens you up to a different
immersive moment so I think I encourage
everyone to go see it what do you love
about IMAX I like a big I mean I think
that if you're going to see a big it
doesn't get any bigger than that and I
like the idea of being it's it's almost
like you're enveloped by the image it's
it allows you to sort of like it's like
the walls disappear and I'm in it I love
that when I see in nature movie when I'm
there and I can see that I love it when
I see one of our films where it it
justifies the bigness of it all I don't
know if that's a word but but it's it
justifies the size of it and I think it
takes you in for a bigger ride but also
it could be it's funny because it's big
but it could be quite intimate and and
that is that's the magic of the format
that sometimes it doesn't matter that
it's so big you're in it and you're in
it to a point of conversion and you're
like wow that is a huge screen and yet
it feels like super intimate so that's
what I love about it you know when I
talked to our post team we sort of
talked about making sure to to you know
deliver this immersive experience and
also to work with the filmmakers to
ensure that what is being put on screen
is exactly what the filmmakers had
envisioned what is that relationship
between Marvel and IMAX you know well
we've always had a really good
relationship with IMAX they're
incredibly respectful of what we do and
how we do it and I think a lot of our
ways of working is that we want to make
sure that is not doubly sharpened that
it doesn't feel too crisp that it has to
feel that the the regular filmed
and also that the color gets transferred
in the right in the right way so we we
are very present and we're in your house
when we're trying to finish this movie
and IMAX has been really kind and
allowing us to do that so we appreciate
that because in a way that's the best
way to respect the the project if if if
if you can put it in any format in a
respect how it was conceived then you
have the best of all worlds you have
every format possible but also it's
protective of how the movie was created
and those are the things like in most
relationships that we have that's the
one thing that we cared to have it as
the most important one so that we can
protect the image as we envisioned it
were there any particular innovations or
new techniques that were sort of
developed for Doctor Strange well we
tried to squeeze 36 hours out of the day
and we failed we couldn't do it we it
didn't help us not even we're trying to
get Doctor Strange to help us to
manipulate time it didn't work we listen
we use everything technically I'm sure
staff will talk to you about everything
that we've done everything that is
available to us we use it everything
that is perhaps available we'll try it
and everything that is not available
we'll ask about it where were those kind
of people were there any particularly
challenging scenes for you
this movie was technically challenging
throughout even some of the what in in
looking at the movie or the scene you go
what that doesn't seem that complicated
technically but the the Astro fight
turned out to be incredibly complicated
in the approach and had to do it so that
it wouldn't look like a ghost
fight or laughable I mean those were the
two things that we consistently wanted
to make sure that you still felt their
strength of this fight and they were
both fighting for their lives and yet to
feel like it was an astral projection
and it was ethereal enough but solid
enough
and it had to have his own light but it
couldn't be the light of the room and
the room had to be changed and every
time of course and every tag there was a
different color pattern that I mean it
was a bit of a struggle and a nightmare
but I think that the final product is
pretty cool
every scene we've done in this movie
whether is the Dark Dimension the astral
projection the magic mystery tour the
mirror the mirror dimension they're
incredibly complicated technically and
also story points to get through in in a
very small amount of time to say so much
about that moment in time that has to
carry through the entire film so we were
I would say we were pretty challenged it
was a constant thing regardless of what
we were at tackling yeah I mean it's
definitely unlike anything we've ever
seen so every topic that we cover in the
film is kind of new well we wanted to do
something different right I mean like
that you have a chance to do something
new so let's take it and it's a
incredibly vulnerable to get out there
and get it done but it's it's a it's a
chance that we had so we took it are
there any shots or scenes in particular
that you're really proud of well I'm
proud that the movie got finished
I'm incredibly fond of the conversation
between the ancient one and dr. strange
and the balcony at the hospital that's
an important conversation for me and it
touches on your life is about the
possibilities and I think that
everything we've tried to do at Marvel
is about the possibilities what if you
get this superhero and you tell their
story so for me it was quite metaphoric
of our journey it's it's about opening
the door and seeing the possibilities
yeah it's a remarkably beautiful scene I
thought so as well and sort of switching
gears just for a moment do you have any
advice or words of wisdom that you would
like to share with people who are
aspiring to work in
our business in the industry and maybe
even who want to work for Marvel well
I'd say know who you are when you go in
stay who you are as you get through and
continue to knock on doors until one
opens I think that people get
discouraged when one door or two or
three or 20 don't open and sometimes
door don't they don't open for a long
time it's it's just a perseverance game
and I call it as a perseverance plus
erosion and either you win by erosion or
by persevering on the erosion that
you're about to win let's keep on going
keep on going keep on going it will
happen eventually but find out why
you're in it what is it that you want to
get out of it because it gets confusing
for some people and why they want to do
certain jobs and it's important to know
what you really want to do and if you
don't that's okay but if if you don't
know what you want to do be open-minded
about the possibilities just try to
figure out which way goes for you at
that moment in time and if that fills
the gap at that moment then that
potentially is the right way to go
so I'd say keep on trying keep on trying
keep on trying and I think this is the
last question but I max is about to
celebrate 50 years of being mainstream
the babies 50 years and 50 practically
twins and you know I max estranged a lot
throughout the years you know we started
off very much in sort of this
documentary institutional film realm and
in the last couple of decades have moved
into Hollywood films and narrative films
how do you think IMAX or the IMAX
experiences sort of changed movie-going
experience over the 50 years
well I think I can only speak about
maybe the last 10 15 I think what is
done it's allowing us to see some
that we care to see other ones in a very
specific environment or something that
we'd like to see multiple times in a
different way so is the chance to
experience and I think that if I had to
define IMAX is is a true experience it's
either an experience of something that
you're repeating because you want to see
it in a different way or is something
that you're going to see it once and
that's going to make a mark and to have
a brand that can do that I think that's
pretty terrific